Harold Reynolds what's up HR random
buddy how you doing I'm better for
talking to you how about that Nationals
team what what is happening right here
do you think so what they you know they
started in 1931 everybody knows that
played terrible but the pitching kept
them together and I remember about July
or August when they start playing great
ball I was like this is the only team
that can beat the Dodgers because
they're built like an old-school team
they've got pitching that goes deep and
that's what we're seeing right now they
put the ball in play last night up
Gerrit Cole didn't give them a lot of
strikeouts and made him work came up
some big hits they're very talented and
the pitching is going to be tough and
right now I'm telling you the [ __ ]
might be looking at being down Oh -
after tonight with Strasburg John Adams
it's you live that you really you really
like the mats to take it tonight - huh
against Verlander well I know Verlander
has been throwing the ball off and on
with different Spurs because he's been
used differently he'll be on great rest
I think he'll be really dynamite but
Stephen Strasburg right now is the best
pitcher in baseball
the last three weeks you can look at
Gerrit Cole scuffled against the Yankees
a little bit got through it last night
got hit Strasburg has just been nails
the fastball to change up the
combination there he's been the best
pitcher right now I think in the last
two weeks I've watched baseball so Wow
Harold I mean where did this where did
this come from I mean obviously you
can't usually put your finger on on
momentum it's so intangible but walk me
through why this is happening you think
with the Nationals well the beginning of
the year had a lot of injuries when Trey
Turner went down you know you hurt his
finger bunting missed about five weeks
with an injury but he played through a
lot of it but the broken finger but he's
back he's one of the top leadoff guys I
love their lineup Adam Eaton scraps he's
hitting in the two spot Soto we watched
last night I've been saying this for a
couple of years I think he's the best
hitter in baseball and then you look at
Rendon had an MVP type of year but it's
been
and Howie Kendrick who have just
extended this line up and before you
know it they got on a roll and things
just fell together for them and we
finding out what clubs can't really
explain it but it's just falling that
way and they've taken off so I'm gonna
ask you yes or no question that's
somewhat unfair but it's a sports talk
radio show so I'm allowed to do this all
right do you think the Nationals would
be in this position if Bryce Harper was
on it as a 300 million dollar contracted
player hard to say I would say no and
not a knock on Bryce I think it's how
they're they're team chains if Bryce is
playing you don't get Howard Kendrick on
the field you don't see eat and come up
and scrap the way does they're a
different ball club you know I think a
lot of times what happens when you have
a star player on your team like that you
build your lineup and your style around
him and they weren't near the aggressive
Club they are right now without Bryce so
they start playing different style
baseball and there are a lot more
aggressive so that's that's no because
they play a different style
Howard Reynolds here on the Rich Eisen
show is it fair to criticize George
Springer for Carlton Fisk King his way
out of the box trying I guess used some
body language to get it out of the yard
and that he wasn't on third he was on
second if he was on third he could've
scored on the subsequent sac fly that
wasn't really a sac fly with with Altuve
where do you stand on that subject from
the eighth inning last night in the game
that otherwise are amazing for Springer
yeah I think he's gotta be a third base
you know I know he watched the ball and
he said there was a guy second it was
tagging up and you know the whole plays
messed up in that mine in my mind then
because he shouldn't be tagging three
halfway it was one out but Springer I
think's got to be a third base that's
just my opinion it's funny I was walking
with my brother Larry today we're going
for a long walk here and we're talking
about it and I said Larry the difference
is 20 years ago 15 years ago our
generation was when a ball hit the
corner and the gap you're thinking 3
these guys today are thinking homerun
and double the
just have it play that their habit we
had a different habit so it's hard to
criticize Springer for the style of play
that they have I mean these are guys
gonna hit 40 whole months I didn't play
that way you know and most guys in our
generation we didn't have the power we
didn't have 6,000 home runs in a season
from all major league baseball it's just
a different mindset so hard to criticize
him I think we should have been a third
base it's no doubt about it in my mind
but it's a different generation a
different time what would be your career
lead in your all-time best in exit
velocity from your career herald like
the hardest home run you ever had what
do you think you would talk to the exit
velocity from your career I would hope
maybe a hundred no I mean that would be
maximum these guys daddy you're probably
gonna hit in the ball if you had a home
run hit a ball 400 350 80 feet or
something like that it's calling it's
gonna be anywhere from 90 to 100 mile an
hour exit velocity but the guys that are
consistently in the hundred 100 1510 is
pretty amazing so I wasn't in that cab
I'm sure MLB Network and we'll talk
about huddle in a second with you Harold
and what's going on with you in that
organization but if you think that
Strasburg has the leg up tonight or the
arm up tonight and the Nats are up - oh
you like the nets to win this World
Series if I'm picking up what you're
putting down
well they leave here - oh you gotta
think they got a chance to win but I can
turn this thing around in a heartbeat
they're they're one of the best teams
that we've seen since MLB network's has
been on it people so eleventh year and I
think it's the best club the difference
is if you ask me that in July and they
blow everybody away right now they're
not clicking on all cylinders you know
Jordan Alvarez is not the rookie we all
thought right three weeks ago
they're not clicking their team's not
hitting and bregma is not he isn't home
but he struck out three times last night
he's not swinging the bat so this is not
the same Club that was hot in July that
everybody was odd about it's a different
team right now
do you think of the signing of David
Ross to be the the new manager of the
Chicago Cubs Herald I mean what do you
got for me over there
no surprise it was his job to lose so to
speak I knew they were going through the
interview process and a couple guys woke
CEO and made him think seconds maybe but
David was always his guy and I think in
the last year and a half two years where
he's been broadcasting but also been
around the organization has really
allowed him to spend time talking seeing
how he views the game so he's been in
the interview process I think in the
last two years it's not just been right
now but they throw them on it he's gonna
be fine he needs to get a bench coach or
somebody help him run the game a little
bit but David Ross Scott's 1000 games
behind home plate you can manage the
game great personality doing a love them
in Chicago and you know I think it's the
perfect guy for the times there is and
the times that they're in is what well
kept saying they're in a transitional
time if you ask me I don't think this is
the club that's running through the
World Series that we said is going to
take over it would be cure I'm curious
to see what's going to happen what
Bryant these are reportedly turned down
200 million dollars already and he's
gonna be a free agent here soon coming
up but they got some tough decisions to
make what are you gonna do it probably
bias what are you gonna do it Cassie
Alex who came in there and played real
well the pitching staffs getting a
little bit older they were able to
develop young position players and some
guys have not panned out so I think
they're in a transition and I think
David Ross is the guy that's going to
take them to the next phase of this
organization whatever direction they go
in all right Hal tell me about huddle
the number one youth recruiting video
platform in the country it's UDL what is
this well if you're a football fan like
I am you know that's the number one
recruiting platform for for football
basketball and soccer and every college
coach or anybody basically you hear
about recruiting you Google at UDL after
the kids name that pops up so available
partner with huddle and say we need to
do this with baseball and softball and
allow kids to build their own platform
it's a great way to be found whether
you're making that little league team or
you want to go to college it's a amazing
platform to build so if you go in huddle
comm slash baseball home comm sauce
softball and there will be a way to show
you how to suit your there's a tutorial
shows you how to shoot your videos and
how to upload them and how to build your
platform and I think it's good a game
changer for baseball well I heard a name
in this conversation hadn't heard in a
long time Larry Reynolds how's your
brother whole time they got a Stanford
reunion coming up this weekend I believe
out of Stanford for 40 years and he's
all fired up about that but no he's
doing well you know it's clients are
playing good he's got Jake Marisnick and
Howie Kendrick in the World Series right
now so he's watching both those guys
he's doing well the agent Larry Reynolds
I remember I remember seeing him all the
time when I was around you and you were
around and I was around ESPN so please
send him my best to HR okay I will you
guys got one last thing before we go go
fight you know I watch every Sunday
morning okay yeah gotta quit let Michael
when these things are putting that thing
on howling man you got you got to take
over and Maruti's been winning a lot to
HR I am currently leading the Picts
contest I did have seven consecutive
lone Wolf's that I nailed in the very
early parts of the season yeah so I was
hot early and I've just been pushing the
wrong buttons but I'm still one up I
think I'm still one up going into this
week but Mariucci hates wearing that
that wolf had it's too damn bad but do
you well ask ask how the poll question
let's count the poll question before I
go out the jam jar who's got the best
chance to knock off the Pats and the AFC
Chiefs Colts Ravens I don't think the
pad to get beat and now the Belichick is
calling the defense against forget about
it that's a rat it's the rap man HR I
love that you're out there watching game
day more
thanks for the pop appreciate it all
right is that showered Reynolds right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app